this is the story of a gun a weapon used
in 19 shootings the most prolific
firearm ever seen by UK police it's now
off the streets and a total of 15 people
have been sentenced for their
involvement in the gangs that handled it
among them the ringleader James Lunt
it's a victory say police for forensic
investigation we knew this weapon if we
looked to target the weapon we would get
the people behind it these individuals
aren't the the old organized crime
groups with loyalty and some sort of
pride in what they do the chaotic
individuals who got a younger age
profile who were very quickly to too
quickly will use firearms to settle
petty disputes the gun is a Beretta 9000
pistol similar to this one it's known by
police as link series 4 it was experts
here at the National ballistics
intelligence service that linked the 19
incidents to one weapon they found that
the gun was first used in 2010 in the
Glasgow area twice in one week between
2010 and 2014 it was used in 16
shootings around Liverpool targeting
buildings and cars as well as people it
then went quiet for three years notably
during this time to well known gang
members Adam Bigley and James Lunt were
in prison sharing the same cell it
reappeared in May 2017 the victim was
shot seven times the motorcycle helmet
he was wearing saved his life police
were now watching Bigley and lunt
closely they were watching when members
of their two gangs met in a Liverpool
playground just hours later police
raided Adam big Lee's home and found the
guns stashed behind a toilet but with
over six thousand firearms incidents
last year making these links was no easy
task
without a serial number it's almost
impossible to tell the difference
between this gun and say the linked
series for they're exactly the same make
model and manufacturer the key then for
police when tracing weapons and
taking them off the streets is not in
the guns themselves but in the bullets
and their casing in fact every
individual weapon leaves totally unique
markings on the ammunition it fires
you've got two cartridge cases of the
microscope left one on the right and I
comparing the fire detail of these well
things say a little bit like a single
bullet barcode fingerprint whatever
analogy you want to use these lines are
all already got pretty oily a
state-of-the-art database allowed
scientists to compare thousands of
samples in just a matter of minutes when
you're searching Laura picked up quite a
number of these links but once you start
getting older shootings the only way
you're ever going to get that sort of
lean is by having an automated system
the team here are investigating dozens
of guns still on the streets boring but
at least the most prolific is now safely
out of the hands of criminals Helen Anne
Smith Sky News